please welcome tsanaya sydney and jimmy
singleton
i
just absolutely am
losing my mind as everybody is over this
film what was it like i mean they're
just
they're our heroes so what was it like
to be our heroes
oh it was incredible they were amazing
and i think demi and i were kind of just
nervous at first but they might have
like star struck because for sure
i mean
they're mostly just funny yeah i feel
like when we when we met them and spoke
with them they were just so fun you know
um you talked about literally everything
but tennis like literally spoke about
everything else in their lives um but it
was really cool for us because we
finally got to see what what it was like
for them
other than what it is that they do and
how they were just as sisters you get to
see them just as venus and sereno when
you meet them it's great and that's such
a great relationship so that kind of
helped us for sure you know okay tell me
about your friendship so you're playing
sisters i have two daughters like what
do you guys do when you're not working
okay i'm usually on the phone with her
yes um like
literally about anything i'll just call
sinai i'd be like sanaya help me what
shoes do i wear with this outfit
i love it i'm guessing
all the time she'll go like hi smile can
you watch me do my biology project yep
she's such a great friend she sat there
and watched me put slices of potatoes
and glasses of salty water and she sat
there and watched the entire time
that's good friendship
what do you think like about will smith
also like
it's so weird it's like you're like hi
we're gonna play
a family
we don't know each other so how did you
guys fast track that because you did the
chemistry is there i'm in how do you
think that worked with will it was real
because we love we love mr wills so much
you know he's to me
like royalty like hollywood royalty and
he's done so much in his career and has
inspired so many people but just when
you talk to him he's so kind and so
humble he's so approachable
didn't he give you um some advice what
did he say to you he told us something
about his grandmother told him when he
was going on tour for the first time his
grandmother said well make sure that you
respect the people that you see and work
with because you may see them on the way
up and you also may see them on the way
down in your career
[Applause]
okay really quickly it's beauty week
here on the show will you play a quick
beauty game with me yeah yeah all right
great okay
it's gonna be a new segment that you
guys are gonna kick off for the first
time on our show and it's make your mark
on the beauty court
okay we're gonna list some current
trends happening and with your tennis
rackets will you tell us whether you
think it's in or it needs to be out okay
all right you ready let's do it all
right here we go sweater vest
oh
yes yes yes oh thank god
i i say both it depends on how it's
styled very end very end i think it's in
most of the time but i've seen some not
and see like with the bags jeans or like
a cute sweater right the way that it's
styled on this girl is really beautiful
like you can go to trader joe's it's
very effortless
are you on trader joe's food
um reviews instagram
no get on it now it's literally it's
amazing it's trader joe's food reviews
and it's a hot tip please be on it and
get ready to drool
utility cargo pants are back as if we
thought we needed them they're all the
rage look it's bella hadid oh in in in
okay i think i have so much baggage with
these pants
i really do i they're this is a no for
me because i was in it the first time
around but maybe
maybe a fresh start is what people need
with thy cargo pant i'm always like are
we cinematographers are we fly fishing
what are we doing right why the need for
that many pockets i don't know if you
really need all you don't need the
pockets but they look cool okay ear
makeup this is hot right now
oh that looks like she has an infection
in her hand
[Applause]
i'm i'm a little that is not that is not
not the ear makeup no that is not it
that is looking a little like jaundice
but that's
what i was about to say
it is but i wouldn't mind seeing this in
another color
i feel like it depends what's what it's
with then maybe it pops you know yeah
ears can pop i guess
[Applause]
i'm so enamored with both of you your
beautiful performances your friendship
your hearts and i'm so excited for
everything that you have to come
congratulations
[Applause]
king richard is in theaters and hbo max
november 19th will smith oscar i'm just
saying that we'll be right back
[Music]